what is a habit a habit is a routine or
behavior that is repeated regularly and
tends to occur subconsciously the
american journal of psychology defines a
habit from the standpoint of psychology
as a more or less fixed way of thinking
willing or feeling acquired through
previous repetition of a mental
experience
how do habits form
according to experts with psychology
today habits form when new behaviors
become automatic and are enacted with
minimum conscious awareness that's
because the behavioral patterns we
repeat most often are literally attached
in our neural pathways
it turns out that every habit starts
with a psychological pattern called a
habit loop which is a three-part process
first there's a cue or a trigger that
tells your brain to go into automatic
mode and let a behavior unfold that's
what we think about when we think about
habits
think about something it took you a
really long time to learn like how to
parallel park at first parallel parking
was difficult and you had to devote a
lot of mental energy to it but after you
grew comfortable with parallel parking
it became much easier almost habitual
you could say parallel parking gambling
exercising brushing your teeth and every
other habit forming activity all follow
the same behavioral and neurological
patterns says new york times business
writer charles duhigg
then there's the routine which is the
behavior itself the third step is the
reward something that your brain likes
that helps it remember the habit loop in
the future
neuroscientists have traced our
habit-making behaviors to a part of the
brain called the basal ganglia
decisions meanwhile are made in a
different part of the brain called the
prefrontal cortex
in fact the brain starts working less
and less the brain can almost completely
shut down and this is a real advantage
because it means you have all of this
mental activity you can devote to
something else that's why it's easy
while driving or parallel parking let's
say to completely focus on something
else like the radio or a conversation
you're having
you can do these complex behaviors
without being mentally aware of it all
and that's because of the capacity of
our basal ganglia to take a behavior and
turn it into an automatic routine
studies have shown that people will
perform automatic behaviors like pulling
out of the driveway or brushing tee the
same way every single time if they're in
the same environment but if they take a
vacation it's likely that the behavior
will change
it's also a great reason why changing a
habit on a vacation is one of the proven
most successful ways to do it if you
want to quit smoking you should stop
smoking while you're on a vacation
because all of your old cues and all of
your old rewards aren't there anymore
so you have this ability to form a new
pattern and hopefully be able to carry
it over into your life in order to gain
good habits and to break the old ones
you need to have a goal the goal helps
you focus on one task at a time having a
goal helps you focus and be productive
at the same time
[Music]
what is a goal a goal is an idea of the
future or desired result that a person
or group of people envision plan and
commit to achieve people endeavor to
reach goals within a finite time by
setting deadlines why is important to
have a goal setting goals helps trigger
new behaviors helps guides your focus
and helps you sustain that momentum in
life goals also help align your focus
and promote a sense of self mastery in
the end you can manage what you don't
measure and you can't improve upon
something that you don't properly manage
how the habits connect with our goal
habits are algorithms operating in the
background that power our lives
good habits help us reach our goals more
effectively and efficiently bad ones
makes things harder or prevent success
entirely habits powerfully influence our
automatic behavior
a lot of people struggle with reading
so let's focus on how to develop a
reading habit instead reading has a
number of benefits including improving
your memory and vocabulary helping you
learn new things and improving focus and
concentration i have used a number of
tricks to help me read more and develop
a daily reading habit first create a
reading list i would definitely suggest
you start out by creating a list of
books that you would like to read for
example you could create a list of
novels that you've always wanted to read
but never had the chance to or a list of
books that you need to read to learn
something about a topic or field of
study that you're interested in
second set a goal a good idea to
motivate yourself to read more is to set
a goal for example you could set a goal
to read a certain number of books this
year or a certain number of pages each
day and then work on reaching that goal
three schedule the time for reading to
make sure that you will read every day
you need to schedule reading into your
day you could read first thing in the
morning during your commute before going
to sleep or even during lunch
4. find a good place to read something
that will help you read more is finding
a good place to read this would
preferably be somewhere quiet without
any distractions you could read in your
bed in a comfortable chair or sofa on a
park bench and of course at the library
5. eliminate distractions make sure to
eliminate any distraction that might be
interfering with your reading turn off
the tv and put your smartphone on silent
6. read actively while passive reading
is better than no reading at all i would
highly suggest you try an active
approach to reading highlight passages
that you think are important or
interesting write comments and notes
either on the book's margins or in a
separate notebook if you're reading on
your smartphone or your ebook reader
take advantage of their highlighting and
note features 7. i highly recommend
keeping a reading journal where you can
write down quotes that you like record
with books you have read jot down any
thoughts related to the book as well as
any comments you have on what you've
read you can review these later to
refresh your memory or to get to new
ideas 8.
carry a book everywhere you go always
carry some reading material with you
either in the form of a physical book or
an ebook on your smartphone or ebook
reader that way you're able to read
whenever you get a chance this allows
you to spend those little breaks in your
day reading instead of scrolling your
facebook or instagram feed 9. know when
to quit don't feel like you have to
finish every book you start if the book
you're reading is boring or not what you
imagine it to be simply drop it and
start reading a different one
a good rule that i like to use is the 50
page rule i always read the first 50
pages of any book i start if i still
don't enjoy it after 50 pages i just
quit and move on to a different book 10.
replace other forms of entertainment
with reading
a good way to read more is to replace
other forms of entertainment with
reading for example instead of watching
tv or movies playing video games or
mindlessly browsing the explore tab on
instagram read a book this will allow
you to read a lot more books every year
11. read multiple books at the same time
something i like to do is read multiple
books at the same time anytime i get
bored with a book or i would like change
of pace i just switch to a different one
a great way to do this is to always read
one fiction book and one non-fiction
book at the same time
12.
get a reading partner you can also get a
reading partner to help you keep
yourself accountable to your reading
goals this can be a friend of yours a
significant other or a colleague you can
start reading the same book with your
reading partner and then discuss it as
you read or once you both finish reading
the book
[Music]
the imitation technique why it's key to
learning languages
[Music]
did you know that if you mimic someone's
accent you'll be able to better
understand what they say
playwright george bernard shaw explains
that connection between learning and
imitation
as such
imitation is not just the sincerest form
of flattery it's the sincerest form of
learning
this is what psychologists at the uk's
university of manchester and holland's
redbound university discovered in a
study in 2010 the results showed that
learning through imitation
imitating the person you're talking to
helps your speech comprehension
so for language learners this imitation
learning technique means it's best to
practice your conversational skills with
a native speaker
imitation speeds up learning
in the 1970s american psychologist
andrew melsov
identified so-called social learning
where people or animals observe and then
copy their companions
imitation accelerates learning and
multiplies learning opportunities he
noted it is faster than individual
discovery it is safer than individual
discovery and safer than learning by
trial and error
practice talking with a native speaker
so if you want to learn a new language
don't just study books
employ the imitation technique by making
contact with native speakers to set up a
language exchange
whether you're looking to learn a few
british english idioms or brush up on
some essential spanish phrases you'll
learn have fun and make new friends all
at the same time
[Music]
hot tip for learning even faster if you
want to speed up the language learning
process
don't simply imitate your partner's way
of speaking accent or intonation try to
use this imitation technique for their
hand gestures and facial expressions too
not only will you sound like a native
speaker you'll also act like one there
are so many benefits to learning a
language like this as well as having a
great time and enjoying interesting
conversations you'll practice your
observation and socializing skills
tell us what you think what languages
have you learned by interacting with
native speakers what extra benefits have
you found and do you have any tips for
successful conversations want to learn a
language by having real life
conversations with native speakers start
learning with busu for free today
[Music]
the emotional rollercoaster of language
learning
you've just decided to learn a language
and you are pumped
we're excited for you but
we also feel the need to warn you
learning the language can be a bit of an
emotional rollercoaster
stage one
so excited
you're going to learn spanish and
impress your boss you're going to learn
arabic so you can finally speak to your
husband's family you're going to laugh
along when the ladies of the nails alone
make fun of you in chinese
because the joke will finally be on them
right
yes you're super excited right now it's
all going to be so much fun
stage two
very confident
you've picked up some study materials
enrolled in a class harassed every
brazilian looking person in a 12 block
radius to practice the 10 words you know
in portuguese
it's new it's fun it's exciting you're
going to be fluent in no time
stage 3
moderately less confident but still
determined
you've made it past the first lesson and
all of the pleasantries are over
no more bonjour a lot more
under
verb conjugations you feel so close to
understanding all these new concepts but
you just keep getting stuck
stage four
struggling
what is that letter am i saying it this
right
am i saying it right
okay so speaking this is a little more
difficult than expected you may or may
not have hugged a logi on your cat while
trying to roll your arse but he'll get
over it
stage five paralyzing self-doubt
well now it's just ridiculous you know a
few hundred words and you can ask for
more bread please so you don't really
need to know anything else anyway right
subjunctive mode
genitive case ain't nobody got time for
that
stage six
regret wait what was the word for bread
i shouldn't have quit learning languages
are awesome what was i thinking
stage seven renewed determination
jump back to stage one
remember how totally fun and interesting
this language is remember that you want
to tell your mother-in-law that you
don't actually like her cooking in
german
that's right get motivated again find
some new resources to make things fun
watch funny youtube videos in italian
read the harry potter novels translated
into dutch they were written for a 14
year old
you don't care nothing can stop you now
stage eight
victory
you just had a conversation in another
language
and they understood that's right your
thai food order came out right
and it was delicious then of course you
try to ask the waiter for the check and
accidentally ask for his phone number
but whatever you're conquering a new
language and it's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to our
channel today we're going to talk about
the fastest most direct ways to learn a
new language
step 1
set language learning goals the first
step to learning a new language fast is
to set goals for what you want to
achieve you think about it this makes a
lot of sense
if you don't set goals how can you know
what you want to achieve and measure
whether you have achieved it or not
when faced with the idea of learning a
new language most of us feel overwhelmed
there are so many words to learn and so
many different ways to study
setting goals narrows your focus so you
can stop worrying about the details and
get down to business research shows that
people who set the right kind of goals
are more likely to achieve success use
these guidelines to get the most from
your goals one focus on specific
tangible outcomes set detailed goals and
focus on what you plan to learn rather
than how much time you plan to study an
example of a good goal might be this
week i'm going to learn 30 spanish
vocabulary words related to shopping
2. set short-term goals it's good to
have an ultimate goal the thing you
eventually hope to achieve but long-term
goals are too overwhelming to motivate
you on an everyday basis break down your
ultimate goal into smaller bits and set
smaller goals for each week or month
three challenge yourself but not too
much
goals work best when they make you push
yourself but if they're too daunting
they can actually discourage you a good
way to get around this is to set goals
with a range of outcomes for example you
might say i want to learn 30 to 50 new
vocabulary words this week
the lower number in this range helps you
feel the goal is achievable while the
higher number allows you to push
yourself three
write down your goals
writing down goals helps you commit to
them
post your goals in a prominent place
like your bathroom mirror or home screen
of your smartphone the second strategy
consists of learning the right words
languages are made up of a shocking
number of words english for example has
between 600 000 and 1 million words
luckily you don't need to learn anywhere
near that many words to be proficient in
a language consider this
the top 100 words make up about 50 of
english language texts and the top 1000
words make up about 90
check out these lists of top 1000 words
in these languages
by focusing on learning these words
first you can eliminate a wasted time
and increase the amount of information
you understand very quickly
tip 3 study smart
when learning your words you'll learn
faster by using the very best study
techniques for example one of the best
ways to learn vocabulary words is to use
flashcards flashcards help you focus on
individual words and allow you to test
yourself which helps you memorize new
information
when you learn with flash cards follow
these tips to learn fast 1. try out
electronic flash cards paper flash cards
work just as well as they ever did but
electronic flash cards programs like
anki provides some great benefits by
using electronic flashcards you can
easily carry large stacks on your
smartphone or tablet and you can take
advantage of flashcards that other
people have created and made public
these programs also automatically change
the order of cards and use space to
repetition to gradually increase the
amount of time between repetitions of a
flash card both of these techniques help
you learn faster and better
next strategy is about making sure to
guess the meaning of a word before
turning over the card flash cards work
best when you use them to test your
memory so don't be too quick to flip the
cards over even if you don't know a word
make a guess
next
learn the translations first then learn
to produce the new words it's easier to
learn the translation of a foreign word
than it is to learn to say the foreign
word when you see its english equivalent
start by looking at the side of a
flashcard with a foreign word on it and
memorize what the english translation is
later turn the cards over and use them
to practice producing the foreign words
when you see their english equivalents
[Music]
you